ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้มาสวัสดีครับนักเรียน
สวัสดีสวัสดีสวัสดีโยเคกว้าวสวัสดีกันอีก
แล้วสวัสดีวันนี้มาเจอพี่จะตีกับน้อง
เรียวในช่องอะไรครับต้องนี้ช่องอะไรตัว
นี่สิเบิ้ลไทยค่ะโน๊ตภัยเย้เย้มาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกันโอเคเออวันนี้วันนี้เรามาเรียน
ภาษาไทยการวันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่ครับ
วันนี้วันที่ 7 ค่ะ 5 วันนี้วันที่ 7
โอเควันที่ 7 นะที่เรียกประกากล่าวเปิดกา
วันนี้วันที่ 7 จะนะอ่าวันนี้วันที่ 7
61เป็นวันอะไรครับวันอะไรครับวันนี้วัน
อังคารค่ะวันอังคาร OK ตั้งแต่วันนี้วัน
ที่ 7 วันอังคารแล้ววันอังคารเดือนอะไร
ครับ
เดือน
ธันวาคมพ.เดือนธันวาคมโอเควันที่ 7
ธันวาคม 5 แล้วปีอะไรครับ
ปีปีสอนอะไรครับอ๋อหน้าคศก่อน
ปีคศ
2000  21 ค่ะพ.ศ
2521 โอเคแล้วปีพศอะไรครับ
E ผช
2564 ค่ะ 5 ใช้ครับพ.ศ.
2564 โอเควันนี้วันนี้วันอังคารใช่ไหม
วันนี้วันอังคารแล้วแอร์เมื่อวานครับ
เมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันอะไรครับ
เมื่อวานอ่าวันจันทร์ค่ะวันนี้วันอังคาร
เมื่อวานเมื่อวานวันจันทร์เมื่อวานวันจัน
วันนี้วันอังคารแล้วพรุ่งนี้ล่ะครับพรุ่ง
นี้พรุ่งนี้ด้านไหนพรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรครับ
พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้พุธอ๋ออ๋อพรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
แค่แต่วันนี้วันอังคารห่าโอเคพี่ครับป้าย
แล้ว a ตอนนี้ท่อนนี่ขี้โมงแล้วครับกี่
โมงแล้วน้ากี่โมงแล้วครับดูนาฬิกา
อ๋อตอนนี้ครับ
07:45 นน
7:00 น
45 เป็นตอนนี้เมื่อเช้าใช่ไหมครับตอน
เช้าค่ะอ้าวเป็นตอนเช้าโอเคตอนเช้าก็พระ
อาทิตย์พระอาทิตย์เพิ่งจะขึ้นมา
อ้าตอนเช้าในครับนะโอเคตอนเช้า 7 โมง 45
นะใช่ไหมวันนี้ยังหนาวอยู่ใช่ไหมครับยัง
หนาวอยู่หนาวค่ะปีใส่เสื้อกันหนาวอ้าน้อง
เรียนใส่ผ้าพันคอคอโอเคเออวันนี้มีอะไรมา
มาคุยกับคุยกับนักเรียนครับวันนี้
วันนี้
มี
คาบสัตว์หน้าภาพสัตว์ใช่ไหมโอเคอ่าเดี๋ยว
เราไปดูภาพสัตว์ตัวตัวที่ 1 ตัวที่ 1
ก่อนนะอ่าโอเคนี่
นะครับหน้าตัวนี้ตัวนี้ตัวอะไรครับน้อง
เรียมรู้จักไหม
ตัวอะไรครับ
ดีหนีหาหมีใช่ไหมครับตัวนี้หมีโห้มีมีตัว
นี้ตัวสีอะไรครับ
หมีขาวหมีสีขาวอ่ะหมีอาคนไทยเรียกหมีข่าว
ไหมครับเนี่ยขาวอ๋อเพราะว่าเพราะว่าตัวสี
ขาวใช่ไหม 5 ตัวสีขาวอ่ะหมีขาว
หมีขาวตัวใหญ่ไหมครับตัวใหญ่
ใช่ค่ะตัวใหญ่มาก
ขาวตัวใหญ่
[เพลง]
โอเคมีหมีขาวนะครับมีภาพมีข่าวแล้วอ่ะ
เบียร์ตี้มีภาพอาอีกนี่ตัวนี้ไอ้ตัวนี้
ตัวอะไรครับ
รู้จักไหม
กระรอกกระรอกอ่ะใช่ครับตัวนี้เป็นกับรอก
กระรอกตัวนี้กำลังทำอะไรอยู่ครับ
กำลัง
ทำไมกินอะไรอยู่อ๋อใช่ไหมกำลังกินกินอะไร
อยู่ครับหน้าอาจจะกินไรค่ะกิน
กินผัวไหมหรือกินอะไรอ่ะอาจจะกิน
อาร์ทัวนะครับหนาวแค่โอ้กรอกเปียเห็นด้าน
หลังด้านหลังของกระรอกตรงนี้ครับนี่
หน้าตรงนี้เรียกอะไรครับที่อยู่ด้านหลัง
หางอ๋ออ๋อเป็นหางใช่ไหมเป็นหางมีหางหาง
กระรอกกระรอกกระรอกมีหารใหญ่หางใหญ่มาก
เลยอ่ะอ่าน้องเรียมเคยเห็นกระรอกน
พี่ที่บ้านหน่อยครับบ้านน้องเรียมมีกับ
รอกไหมมีไหมเรียมเคยเห็นกับบนสายไฟ
จะลอกอยู่บนสายไฟเหรอครับสายไฟ
ค่ะที่มีเสาไฟฟ้า
เสาไฟฟ้า
ใช่ค่ะ
ที่มีสายไฟอา
หมออ๋อแล้วก็มีกระรอกอยู่ไม่มีกระรอกค่ะ
มีกระรอกอยู่ข้างบน
อาการอกขึ้นไปทำอะไรวันเสาร์ไฟอ่าเก่ารอบ
มีเดินๆ
วิ่งๆอ๋ออ๋อมีกระรอกนักหรอกตัวเล็กๆวิ่ง
อยู่บนแต่บ้านพี่อติที่บ้านพี่อาตีกะห์
หรอกไม่ได้อยู่บนใส่ฟ้าฉัน
จะรออยู่บนต้นไม้อยู่บนต้นไม้ไส้ครับน่า
อยู่บนต้นไม้อยู่บนต้นไม้
5 บนต้นไม้มีกระรอกอยู่รอบก็อยู่บนต้น
ไม้
[เพลง]
รอบร้องยังเห็นครับ
เอ๊ย
นักเรียนนักเรียนเคยได้ยินเคยได้ยินเสียง
กระรอกร้องไหม
กระรอกร้อง
กระรอกของไทยนะน่าจะร้องเหมือนกันร้อง
ใช่ไหมใช่แบบนี้ไหมครับเตรียมไม่เคยได้
ยินอ่ามีเป็นเสียงกระรอก
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
อ่าๆ
อีกรอบโอเคกระรอกอยู่นั่นครับที่บ้านของ
นักเรียนครับกะรอบร้องยังไงคะฮ่าๆ
เปียตีคิดค่าเรียนอาจจะทำเสียงกระรอกไม่
ได้พิมพ์พิมพ์เสียงกระรอกก็ไม่ได้ให้
อ่ะแต่พี่อาร์ตี้คิดว่ากระรอกน่าจะร้อง
เหมือนกันนะร้องเสียงเหมือนกันนะเคอ่ะมี
หมีขาวมีขาวนะครับมีกระรอกหน้าแล้วก็มี
นี่ครับตัวนี้
ว้าวนี้ตัวอะไรครับ
ปู๊ดหน้าอูฐพูดคนไทยเรียกอูฐนะที่ประเทศ
ไทยที่ประเทศไทยไม่มีอูฐไม่มีอุดไม่มีค่ะ
ไม่มีไม่มีกูเออ
ปู่ตัวนี้มีอะไรครับ
ปู๊ดสีน้ำตาลหน้าอูฐสีน้ำตาลหน้าโอ้หมู่
น่ารักจังตรงนี้ตรงนี้ 5 ตรงนี้เรียกอะไร
ครับ
เรียก
นอกหาริย์
ดอกหรือโหน่งหน่อเรียกหน่อครับห่าได้งามา
อุดมีนออก 2 ดอกใช่ไหมเพียงตี้เคยเห็นเคย
เห็นอูฐบังตัวพูดบางตัวก็มีหนอกมิ้นออก
เอ่ออันเดียว
ใช่ไหมมเตรียมจับได้ว่าคนไทยเรียกดอก
หรือโหนก
เปียติกิจฟ้าเปิ้ลไทยน่าจะเรียกดอกเรียง
กดกดกดอ่ะโอเคโอเค
โหนกอูฐก็บอกปู๊ดปู๊ดมีหน่อหรือมีโหนก
ครับนักเรียน
นักเรียนอาจจะไม่ได้เรียกว่าหนอนออกหน้า
แล้วพี่อ่ะพี่คิดว่ามันเรียกว่านออกหน้า
กูดต้มมีนออก
อ๋อ
ใช่ไหมหน้าเหมือนวัวเปียตีเคยเห็นวัวก็มี
หนอก
เรียก 2 แบบค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเหรอครับมีคนไทยที่
เรียกดอกกูดหาคนไทยที่เรียกโน่กูดอ๋อล้อ
หรือโน่ก็ได้ใช่ไหม
โอเค
หงส์พูดหน่อโกรธอ๋อก็ได้ยินพูดโหนกอูฐ
โหนกก็ได้และนอกก็ได้อ่านักเรียนนักเรียน
อ่าได้ยินความแตกต่างหากโหนกกับหนอกไหม
เสียงไม่เหมือนกันนะครับไม่เหมือนแต่เอ่อ
เรียกได้เหมือนกันเรียกโหนกโอเคเรียกนอก
โอเคได้เหมือนกันใช้ครับน้าโอเคพูดมี
โหนกฮ่าๆ 2 โหนกนะโอเคอุ่นตัวสีน้ำตาลใช่
ไหมหน้ามีสี่ขาเหมือนกันและอูฐอูฐขายาวขา
ยาวกว่ากระรอกกระรอกขาสั้น
รอกขาสั้นใช่ up นี่ขาสั้นขาสั้นนะครับ
อ่ากูดสูทขายาว
ยาวๆใช่ครับปู๊ดขายาวแล้วอุดก็คอคอก็ยาว
ด้วยขอหย่าก็เลยให้ครับคอยาวยาวเป็นไปยาว
เบียร์ที่ทำคอยาวก็ยาวไม่ได้ไม่ยาว
ขอ VIP ใหม่ยาวข้ออุ่นคออุ่นยาวอ่ายาว
เกย์หาขายาวคอยาวนะโอเคฮะตัวต่อไปตัวต่อ
ไป
หน้าตัวนี้ตัวนี้ตัวนี้เรียกอะไรครับ
กบค่ะอ๋อกบแม่กบตัวนี้ตัวสีอะไรครับ
กบสีเขียวอ้ากบสีเขียวในครับกบสีเขียว
ตั้งลำใช่นะพี่ข้างหลังข้างหลังพี่อ่ะตี
ก็สีเขียวนะครับอ่ะกบกบก็สีเขียว
กบสีเขียวห่ากอล์ฟอันนี้กบตัวนี้ทำอะไร
อยู่ครับ
กบนั่งห้าใช่ครับกบนั่งอยู่นี่กบนั่งอยู่
อ่ะเอ๊ะเฮียตี้เบียร์ตีเห็นว่ากบกบตัวนี้
กบตัวนี้มี 4 ขาเหมือนกันนี่หนึ่งขา 2 ขา
3 ขา 4 คะแต่แต่เพียงตี้ไม่เห็นไม่เห็น
หางครับ
กบห่างไหมก็มีหางไหมกบโตแล้วไม่มีหางอ๋อ
อ๋อกบไม่มีหางหน้ากบไม่มีหางเหมือนอูฐอูฐ
มีหางใช่ไหมครับกูใช้หางกระรอกกระรอกก็มี
หางอาหารยาวนะครับหมีหมี
ก็มีหางหน้ามีก็มีหางเพลงกบกบไม่มีไม่มี
หากบไม่มีหางอ๋ออ๋อกบไม่มีหางมาพี่
อาร์ตี้ค่ะขับกบนั่งเตรียมก็นั่งเตรียมก็
นั่งใช่เตรียมยืน
ขากบยืนยังไงค่ะกบกบไม่ยืนกบไม่ลืมใช่เขา
เรียมยืน
กบยืนได้กบไม่ยืนกบไม่หยุดไม่ยืมกบนั่งกบ
หน้านะเทพนั่งกบนั่งๆครับอ่า
ขูดยืนปูดยืนได้เลยครับกะรอกรอบก็ยืนได้
ยื่นได้ได้ครับหมีหมีก็ยืนได้เหมือนกัน
เรียนได้ได้ครับแตกพี่กบไม่ยืนงานกบ
กระโดดกระโดด
ใช่ครับกระโดดไป
โอเคกบกระโดดเตี้ยที่ตีไม่ถามไม่ถาม
ไม่ถามว่ากบรอเคียงไง
กบร้องได้
ร้องได้เหรอครับ
อาจบรอบน้องยังไงครับอบอ๊บๆก็พกโอเคกบ
ประเทศไทยร้องอบๆใช่ไหม
กบกบที่บ้านนักเรียนร้องยังไงครับ
กบร้องยังไงคะอบร้องยังไง
ก๊อบมีกบบังตัวร้อง s หน่อยพบ
และพบๆเฮียตบขอ
ไอ้เขียดร้อยเอ็ดเย้ๆ
โอเคโอเคอันนี้เป็นกบอ่ะเดี๋ยวเคลียร์ตี
จะพาไปดูพาไปดูที่อยู่ที่อยู่ของกบที่
อยู่ของอะไร up กระรอกที่อยู่ของอูฐแล้ว
ก็ที่อยู่ของอะไรอีกหมีขาวใช่ไหมอ้าวๆ
อยู่ที่ไหนเออนี่ครับ
ที่อยู่ที่อยู่ก็คือ
คือที่ที่ที่ที่ที่ๆกรอบที่มีขาวนอนที่
อาศัยอยู่ในกับหาอาหารกินกินอาหาร
นอนแล้วก็อยู่เหมือนจะตีเพียงติดที่อยู่
ที่ไหนคะอ่าพี่หนูอยู่อาภิบาลอะอยู่ที่
บ้านใช่ได้ครับพี่ที่อยู่ในบ้านนะ
จ๊ะหนูของเรียมก็ที่บ้านขออยู่ที่บ้าน
เหมือนกันอ่าบ้านของบ้านของเอ่อบ้านของกบ
ก็มีบ้านของหมีก็มีอ้าเดี๋ยวเราจะไปเรียน
เรื่องบ้านของนายกบของหมีหน้าโอเคอะเอา
อ่าที่อยู่ที่แรกนะที่อยู่ที่แรกอันนี้
เป็นเอาอันนี้ก่อนหน้านี้เป็นอะไรครับ
ทะเลทรายหน้านี่ตรงนี้เป็นทรายมีทรายเยอะ
เลยนะครับมีทรายเยอะนี่เรียกคนไทยเรียก
ทะเลทรายแล้วที่มีสายสายๆครับอ่ะทะเลทราย
แล้วหาครับเริ่มต้นต้นอะไรคะอ้าอันนี้
เป็นต้นอะไร The  Stick คิดว่าเป็นต้น
มะพร้าวไหมเหมือนไหม
[เพลง]
คุณ
อินทผาลัมไมคราฟเป็นต้นอินทผาลัมเหรอ
อินทผาลัมมันลูกเล็กไหม
อินทผาลัมมันลูกเล็กๆใช่ไหมครับแต่นี้ลูก
ใหญ่เพศที่ไม่แน่ใจอาจจะเป็นต้นมะพร้าว
หรือเปล่าไม่รู้เป็นต้นไม้ต้นไม้ที่อยู่
อยู่ที่ไหนครับอยู่ในทะเลทรายอ่าทะเลทราย
ในทะเลทรายร้อน
ร้อนทะเลทรายร้อนใช่ครับทะเลทรายร้อนแล้ว
ก็มีทรายมีทรายเยอะเนอะโอเค
15 แล้วต่อมาครับรูปนี้เป็นอะไรครับอ่า
เสือภูเขาน้ำแข็งอ่ะใช่ครับเป็นภูเขาภู
เขาน้ำแข็ง 5 ภูเขาน้ำแข็งก็จะเป็นไงครับ
หนาวไหมขาวอ้าเป็นสีขาวแล้วก็หนาว
หนาวมีภูเขาน้ำแข็งแล้วก็มีน้ำอยู่เดี๋ยว
นี้เป็นทะเล
นะอ่าเป็นทะเลและมีผู้เขาน้ำแข็งน้ำๆโอเค
น้องเรียมคิดคิดว่าคิดว่าอา
หมีหมีขาวตัวนี้ครับหมีขาวตัวนี้
บ้านของหมีขาวอยู่ที่ไหนครับอยู่ที่ทะเล
ทราย
หรืออยู่ที่ภูเขาน้ำแข็งครับอ่ะ
เฮ้อออออออร์ดบทเวลาอยู่ที่ไหนครับเตรียม
คิดว่าหมีขาวอยู่ที่
ภูเขาน้ำแข็งอ่ะอ้าวเตรียมคิดว่าหมีขาว
อยู่ที่ภูเขาน้ำแข็งแล้วนักเรียนล่ะครับ
นักเรียนคิดว่าหมีหมีขาวอยู่ที่ภูเขาน้ำ
แข็งหรืออยู่ที่ทะเลทรายครับน้า
โอเคแต่เพื่อติ๊กคิดว่านักเรียนก็รู้
เหมือนกันว่าหมีหมีขาวต้องอยู่ที่ภูเขา
น้ำแข็งด้านน่ะ yeti ชี้ผิดด้านและอาจหาญ
ไม่เจออยู่ที่ภูเขาน้ำแข็งถูกต้องครับอ่ะ
อ่ะหมีขาวชอบอากาศหนาวหน้ามีถ้าชอบอากาศ
หนาวชาอยู่ที่ภูเขาน้ำแข็งนะอ่าโอเคคะแนน
บ่แม่นโอเคอ่าภาพต่อไปนะครับ
อาตมาอันนี้มีโอมีภูเขาน้ำแข็งแล้วก็มี
อะไรครับอันนี้
ต้นไม้ไม้โอเคมีต้นไม้กับภูเขาน้ำแข็งอ่า
น้องเรียมคิดว่านี่ตัวอะไรครับเป็นจำได้
ไหมตัวอะไรตัวอะไรครับทุเรียนจำได้ไหมคะ
ตัวอะไรตัวนี้จะรอกรอกใช่ครับมาแล้ว
กระรอกกระรอกกระรอกอยู่ที่ภูเขาน้ำแข็ง
หรืออยู่ที่ต้นไม้ครับ
บ้านของกระรอกอยู่ที่ไหนครับอ่า
อ๋ออ่อที่อยู่ที่ไหนครับ
จะรอกอยู่
บนต้นไม้อ่าใช่ครับกระรอกอยู่บนเริ่มต้น
ไม้กระรอกไม่อยู่บนเสาไฟนะก้อ
เคยอยู่บนสายไฟนะไม่เลี้ยงเห็นเดี๋ยวรอก
รออยู่บนต้นไม้อ่า
ใช่โอเค
โอเคอ่ากระรอกอยู่บนต้นไม้อ่ะไอ้ตี
ต่อไปรูปต่อไปอะมีต้นไม้นามิต้นไม้แล้วก็
มีโอะโอ๋อันนี้อันนี้อะไรครับ
บ่อน้ำค่ะค่ะบ่อน้ำมีบ่อน้ำกับต้นไม้
KR นักเรียนหน้าน้องเรียมคิดว่าตัวนี้จะ
มีตัวไรครับพบๆ
กบสิฮะกบหน้ากบอยู่บนต้นไม้หรือก็อยู่ใน
บ่อน้ำครับอานาอยู่ที่ไหนครับอาอยู่ที่
ไหนครับ
ต้นไม้ไหมหรืออยู่โดดดีบ่อน้ำใช่
กระโดด
อ่ากระโดดไปที่ไหนครับบ่อน้ำค่ะอ้าโอเคกบ
กันหนไม่อยู่ในบ่อน้ำใช่ไหมวะวะว้าวๆๆ ok
ถูกต้องครับกบอยู่ที่บ่อน้ำโอเคเดี๋ยวนะ
ครบหรือยังครบหรือยังครับ
ยังไม่ครบใช่ไหมอ่าตอนนี้มีบ่อน้ำ
แล้วก็มีทะเลทรายอาเหลือตัวอะไรครับขูด
ปูน 5 อุดอุดอยู่ที่ไหนครับอยู่ในบ่อน้ำ
หรืออยู่ในทะเลทรายครับอ่า
แต่น้าโอเค
คิดเปรียบคิดว่าหาหมู่อยู่ในทะเลทรายอา
ใช่ครับปู๊ดอยู่ในทะเลทรายของคายเพราะกูด
ไม่ชอบไม่ชอบอยู่ในน้ำอุ่นอยู่ในน้ำไม่
ได้ 5 กูดอยู่ในทะเลทรายอ้าๆครับน้า
โอเคแล้วก็วันนี้เราได้รู้จักกับสัตว์ไป R
4 ตัวเลยใช่ไหมครับมีตัวอะไรบ้างนะครับ
หน้ามีหมีขาวขาวมี
ก็ร้องโอเคมี
ขูดขูดนะโอเคเราก็มี
กบกบน้าโบ้โอเคเยี่ยมเลยนะไว้เราได้รู้
จักสัตว์ไปทั้งหมด 4 ตัวและก็รู้ด้วยว่า
สัตว์อยู่ที่ไหนบ้านของสัตว์ต่างๆอยู่ที่
ไหนนะครับถ้านักเรียนคนไหนพึ่งเข้ามา
เพิ่งเข้ามาดูครัวตีกับน้องเรียมย้อนกลับ
ไปดูตอนต้นคลิปหน้าเราจะบอกว่ากบอยู่ที่
ไหนมีขาวอยู่ที่ไหนสร้างใช่โอเคเอาวันนี้
ครับวันนี้หมดเวลาอีกแล้วบทโดยเวลาอีก
แล้ว
ใช้กันหมดแล้ว
แล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้านะคราวหน้ากลับมาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกับเพียร์ตีกับน้องเรียมกันใหม่ใน
ช่องช่องคอมที่เห็นบอกเอ้อไทยแล้วโอเค
ครับแล้วเจอกันใหม่คราวหน้าครับวันนี้
สวัสดีครับบ๊ายบายดีค่ะเพื่อนสวัสดีครับ
โรงเรียนเย้ตีสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนม
ม.ค